city leaders coming together tonight in  support of mental wellness and teens and  children community advocates were on  hand talking about the importance of  mental health and how vital it is to get  help if you or a loved one is struggling  las vegas raider solomon thomas was  there to get the message out that it's  okay to not be okay  i think you know a lot of like prime  time athletes and big athletes coming  out speaking have let everyone else in  the world know how  you know they're just like everyone else  how you know mental health doesn't  discriminate no matter how much money  you have how successful how famous  each of the organizations on hand  tonight were given ten thousand dollars  by the san manuel band of mission  indians